on passe maintenant donc à l'interview
de la vraie emmanuelle béart
c'est l'interview de cette dame à
l'élégance et la non personne n'à
connaît sa première il peut aider oui
emmanuelle béart quel défaut doit avoir
un homme pour vous séduire ou tout ce qu
elle l insulte qui vous a fait le plus
plaisir des horreurs qui me viennent en
plus les passants à contenir sinon quel
compliment qui vous énerve le plus aucun
compliment de l'est mais n'y est pas bon
donc quand on vous dit que cette très
belle en couverture de elle en fait ça
très bien
qu'est ce que vous voudriez que vos
enfants rate attend pas leur bac en tout
cas pas leur vie non je voudrais que tu
attends je sais pas c'est bizarre comme
question à mon marathon dans ces moments
là oui vous avez bien compris la
traversée de cet intérieur
le le magma firat le conservatoire
voilà qui ratent leur première cigarette
qui rate voilà plein de trucs
qu'est-ce que vous interdisait à vos
enfants que vous ne vous interdisez pas
à vous même comme l'autre c'est comme
notre question d'un très mauvais c'est
tout ce que tout ce moment je ne sais
pas chez pas dans l'interdiction je ne
sais pas comme ça que pour quelles
raisons seriez vous capable de refuser
votre plus belle histoire d'amour
je ne refuserai jamais ma plus belle
histoire d'amour mais je suis demande us
et les pales et rier quel est le talent
que vous n'aimeriez pas avoir le talent
que je n'aimerais pas voir mais c'est
une drôle de truc tout pour monter
lentement t je suis une honteuse
ah oui c'est vrai j'en ai fait mon
métier donc voleuse aussi on ans les
gens me voient le jour où le ça m'est
arrivé mais des trucs pas grave non
commun
des détournements des petits trucs
justement vous aimeriez pas marche pas
dissimulatrice ou non non non ça j'aime
bien tout ça bernard enfin bernard senon
ashanti dob
sinon à ce club mais c'est pas un talent
et non comédienne dans une autre
interview
tiens on va finir celle là déjà qui fini
ton assiette
alors on va faire plus simple manuel
quel est le film à succès que vous êtes
contente d'avoir refusé mais j'ai jamais
refusé un film qui a eu du succès ouais
quel est le bide qu'elle vous êtes
content d'avoir participé
le dernier film de rivette régis lien
par kia me rioux est détesté par plein
de gens qui meurent jeunes s'ils n'ont
pas n'ont même je parle pourquoi pas par
part qu il faut j'ai choisi ce quelqu'un
en tout cas durant germeront nessma
sarkozy ah oui non dits n'habite pas le
11e rennais sont valables qu est la
question qu il ne faut pas que je vous
pose non toutes les questions sont
valables c'est vrai moi mais c'est sain
avec le temps il n'y a plus de question
qu'on peut non et d'ici six mois
horribles
non pas du tout chez